[Musica]
150.000 sono i modi diversi per
innamorarsi della seta dei ragni è sì
perché sono 150 mila le diverse
tipologie di seta che questi animali
riescono a produrre ognuna delle quali
con proprietà e funzioni completamente
diverse pensate che alcuni ragni usano
la seta in un sistema simil carrucole
che permette loro di sollevare prede
fino anche a mille volte più pesante di
loro come questa povera lucertola sempre
per cacciare il ragno Bolas usa la seta
come Lazzo e cattura il volo maschi di
falene notturne che sono state attirati
prima tramite l'emissione di un forte
odore di femmina davvero ingegnosa no ma
non solo i ragni usano la seta per molte
altre azioni alcuni maschi ci
costruiscono dei doni nuziali da
regalare alle femmine prima degli altri
elementi per evitare il cannibalismo
sessuale ovviamente mentre altri un
pochino meno romantici preferiscono
legarle con la seta e tenerle ferme
si può dunque dire che è proprio grazie
alla seta che i ragni hanno conquistato
il nostro pianeta impattando nei suoi
ecosistemi questi animali mangiano
all'anno circa 800 milioni di tonnellate
di prede e guardate che la massa degli
uomini di 500 milioni di tonnellate e
dunque sono un'arma fortissima per
combattere la diffusione di insetti
invasivi per l'agricoltura oppure per
combattere la diffusione di malattie
come la malaria dato che in Africa
alcuni ragni si sono specializzati nella
caccia di zanzare che hanno fatto il
pasto di sangue questa capacità dei
ragni di adattarsi a quasi tutti gli
ambienti si riflette in una loro
incredibile varietà nel corso dei 400
milioni di anni i ragni sono più vecchi
dei dinosauri questi animali hanno
sviluppato comportamenti e forme
diversissime alcuni ragni assomigliano a
dei Pokémon location altri invece
adescrementi di uccelli mentre altri a
disegni ben noti perché come me Ama gli
snack e le patatine
i ragni sono animali tanto importanti
quanto complessi che solo oggi
incominciamo a conoscere pensate che
recentemente si è scoperto che alcuni
ragni sembrano avere una fase di sonno
simile alla nostra fase REM il che apre
numerosissime porte per espandere la
nostra conoscenza sul sonno ma anche
farci riflettere sul fatto che animali
così piccoli hanno comportamenti simili
ai nostri Ma volete sapere qual è la
cosa più bella del fatto che i ragni
sognano è che lo fanno appesi ad un filo
di seta Ecco che ritorna alla seta
presente anche durante il sonno di
questi animali ma insomma ma se ragnano
usato la seta Praticamente per qualsiasi
cosa e con essa ci hanno conquistato il
mondo perché non lo possiamo fare anche
noi
fatta quasi interamente da proteine la
seta di ragno è un materiale
resistentissimo come l'acciaio Ma è
molto più deformabile è una fibra sette
volte più leggera quindi un materiale
incredibile pensate filato a temperatura
ambiente usando esclusivamente acqua
al contrario il Kevlar una delle fibre
più performanti del mondo umano che
viene utilizzata per rinforzare le corde
di arrampicata la tuta di Valentino
Rossi persino la tuta di Batman è una
Fibra che viene filata in acido
solforico concentrato e temperature che
sfiorano i 100 gradi centigradi
condizione molto lontane dalla
sostenibilità allo stesso modo molte
delle fibre tessili che oggi Indossiamo
sono fatte da materiali plastici il cui
uso tenderà ad aumentare nel corso dei
prossimi anni incentivato sempre di più
da modalità di consumo come la fast
fashion che hanno portato quasi il
raddoppio della produzione di vestiti
dal 2015 ad oggi diminuendone però il
tempo di utilizzo di oltre il 40%. il
risultato è che il 10% dell'inquinamento
globale è causato dall'industria della
moda come risolviamo questa cosa è di
certo Questo non è un problema semplice
e quindi non ci possono essere soluzioni
altrettanto semplici però la seta offre
un'ottima possibilità per sviluppare
soluzioni ecosostenibili per l'industria
tessile e non solo è sì perché grazie
alle sue proprietà meccaniche questo
materiale anche perfetto per sviluppare
tecnologia per l'elettronica soffice lo
abbiamo fatto recentemente ibridandola
con leghe metalliche e donandole anche
proprietà magnetiche e elettriche ma non
solo vista la sua natura proteica questo
materiale è anche perfetto per
sviluppare tecnologie biomedicale Ad
esempio in ambito di ingegneria
tessutale recentemente abbiamo
dimostrato che la seta di ragno Può
essere utilizzata per rigenerare le ossa
i muscoli ma anche i nervi
sebbene tutte queste possibilità siano
estremamente eccitanti Dobbiamo però
scontrarci con un problema il fatto che
non possiamo produrre seta di ragno su
scale industriale Perché i ragni sono
cannibali e quindi non possiamo metterli
tutti insieme Sperando poi di
raccogliere la loro seta Bisogna pensare
ad altre soluzioni
a riguardo i batteri offrono un'ottima
opportunità per sviluppare proteine
della seta artificiale
recentemente abbiamo sviluppato un
protocollo che utilizza un bio reattore
per produrre proteine della seta di
ragno artificialmente in soluzione
acquosa e in quantità compatibili con la
scala industriale
e una volta che abbiamo questa brodaglia
di proteine Come facciamo a filare le
fibre beh A tal riguardo la cosa
migliore è sicuramente quella di farsi
ispirare dai nostri amici ad otto zampe
sviluppando un processo di filatura bio
mimetico che utilizza quasi
esclusivamente acqua per produrre queste
fibre incredibili però i ragni ci hanno
messo milioni di anni per perfezionare
questa tecnica di filatura e
comprenderla in pieno non è facile
un'altra sfida difficile Infatti Sebbene
le fibre che produciamo abbiano ottime
proprietà meccaniche e biologiche ancora
non sono all'altezza delle loro
controparte naturali
il processo di filatura della seta è
complicatissimo e coinvolge fenomeni che
spazzano dalla fluidodinamica alla
biochimica Inoltre questi fenomeni non
accadono indipendentemente il che rende
le cose ancora più difficili
l'unico modo che abbiamo per affrontare
questa cosa qua che non è semplice E non
vi aspettate che vi dicessi che tutta
era semplice e quella di approcciarla
con un approccio multidisciplinare Io
sono un fisico e da solo non ce la
potrei mai fare per risolvere questa
cosa qua serve un team con competenze
eterogenee per fortuna nel team in cui
lavoro ci sono Biologi biochimici
chimici ingegneri persino veterinari che
sono sempre pronti ad insegnarmi cose
nuove
Ma anche così non è semplice
recentemente siamo stati coinvolti in
uno degli Studi più grandi che la
comunità della seta abbia mai visto in 8
anni più di 40 scienziati da ogni parte
del mondo Australia Giappone Europa
America hanno studiato oltre mille
tipologie diverse di seta di ragno per
cerchi per cercare delle regolarità che
aiutassero poi a progettare le fibre
artificiali il risultato dello studio è
che di strada da fare Ne abbiamo ancora
tanta apparentemente non ci sono
definite regolarità indice del fatto che
questo materiale la seta di ragno rimane
ancora elusivo sotto moltissimi aspetti
ecco dunque che sembra non finire mai un
problema Quello della moda sostenibile
estremamente complicato la cui soluzione
parziale la sete di ragno pone sfide
altrettanto complicate
sembra quasi di vivere all'interno di
una matrioska la complessità dentro la
complessità
che cosa ci rimane da tutto questo
io sono convinto che l'obiettivo di
arrivare per un ad un mondo più avanzato
tecnologicamente e più pulito passi
anche attraverso lo sviluppo di
tecnologie basate sulla seta Se chiudo
gli occhi Posso vedere la seta entrare
nelle magliette che Indossiamo tutti i
giorni oppure durante le operazioni
chirurgiche in tecnologia biomedicali ma
magari anche per sviluppare corde per
dondolarsi tra i palazzi delle città
però la seta può solo contribuire
marginalmente nel portarci verso un
mondo migliore perché il problema è
enorme
del resto la nostra società è complessa
e ci pone sfide sempre più difficili è
impossibile pensare che ci siano
soluzioni veloci e semplici a questi
problemi
allo stesso tempo la società in cui
viviamo è sempre più fragile il covip e
la guerra ce l'hanno insegnato È un po'
come una Palafitta abbiamo pochi
pilastri che ci sorreggono in un terreno
estremamente cedevole rendendo il tutto
molto più precario
l'unico modo che abbiamo per
fronteggiare questa fragilità è educare
alla creazione di connessioni sociali e
professionali ma anche all'elasticità
mentale dobbiamo riempire gli spazi tra
i pilastri di questa Palafitta e creare
delle solide fondamenta
i ragni e la loro seta mi hanno
insegnato che la complessità e la
diversità si devono affrontare senza
esclusività mentale imparando anche a
chiedere aiuto per fare questo dobbiamo
educare le generazioni future ad una
maggiore elasticità e forse a riguardo
converrebbe farsi ispirare dai bambini e
alla loro genuina curiosità
io sogno una società diversa più
elastica mentalmente e interconnessa
pronta ad affrontare le sfide dei
cambiamenti climatici l'inquinamento i
regimi autoritari le malattie il
razzismo io sogno una società anche
sorretta dalla seta di ragno proprio
come ragno sognava appeso al suo filo
Grazie
[Applauso]